[Music]
in I'm loving it news oh [ __ ] the people
that won't sponsor me to save my [ __ ]
life even though you did a photo you
know professional photo shoot with their
product are you did I did did you tag I
should have tagged him but then I'm a
little bit salty right now they should
be a little more open-minded yeah I
think so submitted by Jill Molly and
Baker oh there's no Baker just food
lines yeah he's got my bread lines
everywhere MREs they're busy making the
bread for the bed like a group of
scantily clad girls stormed into
McDonald's and started eating everyone's
food in a seduction experiment I would
kick their [ __ ] ass can I get some
fries but what if it's like what if it's
just like one fry and then she just does
this take it if she doesn't go no I
think this is just hungry models who got
to go into a McDonald's I believe so and
they're like yeah you know I mean like
what is oh god what is all this
see I really wish I was in that
restaurant cuz I kid you not I would
definitely have done that especially if
I don't know them were they only going
up to men I'll show you guys a video oh
there's a video yes I ate french fry
they sure you know what they should have
done is Carl's jr. who's that being a
little more playful with the whole ad
campaign that they have that's true they
have those girls yeah that's true but
this took place in Moscow okay Oh
Russians are like wetted down and then I
will eat my food for sure yeah no
offense to definitely
[ __ ] fine you just have the bottom
line wait a minute you know who's hot
Czech girls oh yeah in Prague that's all
I'm gonna go to Prague so back you see
guys just so that for eye candy it's not
just a sext if he's a man he needs to
connect I know he's the [ __ ] material
Hey definitely will let it let them eat
my food now you're coming here my all
those morals are their hookers I don't
know yeah that was us back in the days
are they like Victoria's Secret models
with their wings and stuff they took
this is this a YouTube prank video like
what the [ __ ] is going on this is a
seduction experiment led by it's not an
experiment how they're not getting
arrested that's right we're going after
them you can only he's like this is a
business and in my spanking first of all
this is the dope ass [ __ ] McDonald's
yeah it's like a coffee shop what is it
since the to school oh we went to in
France was like that just over European
like non-american what they build them
upwards rather than having land to the
billet wines like straight up if I'm
eating my burger and she tries to grab
my burger
the first she's only getting a fry she's
not like taking the whole seat she
grabbed the drink and she drank out of
the deuce drink look at the [ __ ] man
what if he had herpes
yeah no no no you like Det hope that's
dirty
yeah if there's some screenshots of that
video oh they're just like
average-looking girls but just in
lingerie
yeah are you know when girls do just
like that they become hotter that's
really that's like you tell you to buy
me lunch right
I will it can't be you just walking up
and taking the food there has to be an
action of sexuality first like you had
to have come up stroke my dick you could
have a bite of the burger it's a
different story maybe it's a trades call
trades illegal trade I straight
they were picking their victims they
weren't picking the fat guys maybe
that's right oh that's not true they
didn't really play into it going what
should have happened like they should
have been like this yeah and bad that's
right that burger no but they were like
kind of like distancing miserly yeah
first scenario we were gonna [ __ ] second
scenario just a thief yeah yeah so this
whole thing was it's part of a seduction
training course that was ran by a sex
guru named Alex that makes sense why the
girls look just average but in lingerie
because they're taking the course to
learn how to be seductive exactly so
this you don't take myself Alex lovely
he will be running against president
Belgium and Vladimir Vladimir he'll do
really well yes next year's election and
so he campaign slogan is this a country
led by a military man will fight a
country led by a scientist will develop
a country that is run by a sex guru will
multiply that's his slogan home campaign
slogan then I want the scientists really
good so you want to turn Russia into why
China just want to multiply all the hell
come on turn weekend Russia into a
burlesque show like what what did they
learn from the experiment so the Lopez
guys are horny I knew that [ __ ] what
anyone seen your picture of their asses
so this is a after they were leaving the
McDonald's they went inside of this limo
so you're all the girls in the limo and
they're ugly
[Laughter]
it's just average women in in scantily
clad dancer the one in the back is
actually pretty damn hot oh I think I
wouldn't say that's pretty hot and the
Steve approves of all I'm being honest
Hey
maybe my standards are a little lower
than gages did Casey's like only [ __ ]
man you tell me you wouldn't what I'm
saying is that his perception of what
the Russian Czech women was here he
expected that so if you ever watch
Russian porn
like I can't say that I know when it's
Russian porn so they just look like why
you should you should look it up in the
next time yeah like I'm talking about
like Russian porn and the titles are all
in Russian too like it's like the
Russian language it's like all of a
sudden dogs start coding Alex dude with
all his students oh now I know what the
experiment is is he wearing a dress I
don't want him to run a country that's
cold oh wait he's going up against Putin
dude he's gonna I don't have elections
dude he's just a prop yeah he's gonna be
great because if he does become
president than the official clothes for
all women is gonna be lingerie yeah so
when they went inside the limo he
started scolding the girls saying like
what did you buy food you're supposed to
go in there and just take it and show
your dominance with your seduction and
the girls are like that's what we did
and he was like all perfect good job
then he thought that they bought the
food yeah so they were like no we didn't
we don't get to you don't take my food
that's not good ship skills right
they're already like why do you start
chastising without knowing the facts my
thing is I just don't get the point of
it and yeah like so many social
experiments I'm like there's no point to
this it's just it's always something
ham-handed or really Forster or it's
just like hey because we call it a
social experiment we have a right to be
[ __ ] to people yeah like always that
like like the pranking yeah yeah yeah
but like walk if I walk up to you and I
snatch your burger I'm being a dick and
like if you react to that I can't
believe you reacted to that it's like
that's a very normal reaction to do that
omnipresent nowadays it seems to be this
other thing where it's like just find
the show creator [ __ ] him up and go it's
a social experiment thank you I just
wanted to see how a TV show producer or
YouTube channel producer would would
react if I [ __ ] does that suck for doing
this we we I pulled out a suicide vest
while I was on a plane Oh
social experiment why is it oh [ __ ] dude
it's a social experiment you
close-minded [ __ ] yeah see what I'm
saying it's like that's a natural
reaction of course it's totally paper
wrote it's a prank bro nobody cares bro
oh my god yeah but they're saying that
this is a field exercise to show the
trainees that they can do whatever they
want by using their special female
charms well yeah it's not as mystery to
the world that's that's print been
established for thousands of years
trainee the tree means like there you
just have one of these girls just Todd
go up to a man say would you like to
take me to dinner tonight the guy will
say yes immediately he will take them to
dinner and you can prove it that way
yeah that's I mean it's like no [ __ ]
this is not funny how that they need a
school for seduction I felt like it's
just pretty easy to seduce a guy no I
don't I don't seduce do I never seduce
right no not really you don't need to
know the thing is you don't need to
seduce you just need to look pretty and
guys get seduced by you walking down the
street no it's funny because whenever I
try to seduce you I always have to joke
and we do it I can never be like we just
start laughing together what do you do
with your mom well don't ever do that
you like Jesus father said I do that
means the do you see guys like shoulder
stuff I read put your dick here if you
want
[Laughter]
we should have shoulders now that's time
just like you have sex
[Music]
boy the casino does bunt Dan and Dan bed
combine a bus ticket on the bus yeah
yeah there's no artist deduction here
what you guys do Nicky just usually is
like hey I need some [ __ ] on my own
Joe but do you ever try to seduce her
um all the time all day long and never
almost ever works because she's usually
very busy she's in she's editing all day
and her jammies on and give one [ __ ]
because I will I will hit at any time
from any angles anything but you know
cuz we're we're at home all day with
each other and so I'm always like I'm
always bird dogging on her dude she
can't walk around the house with how
many be like it's a dutchie movie where
are you going how steep and I can't
believe it doesn't work what's up you
sexy [ __ ] useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you want to follow us you
could check out all our [ __ ] links in
the description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then that videos are up
there
[Music]